vous vous souvenez giscard d'estaing oui
je sais pas s'ils se souvient de moi oui
mais oui mais il faut répondre oui mais
ouais on va faire une interview oui mais
[Musique]
je ne suis peut-être pas le meilleur
comique du monde mais mais
je regarde les cassettes de jean roucas
pour m'améliorer c'est ça le principe
voilà d'accord je ne ferai pas comique à
la télé toute ma vie mais mais tant que
je ferai de la télé j'essaierai de
rester comique l'esprit canal n'est pas
mort mais il était temps que j'arrive ça
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai j'aime
bien la nouvelle émission de michel
denisot mais mais le vrai spectacle sur
canal démarre le vendredi soir stéphane
bern et franchement drôle mais mais
personnes se rencontrent
je ne suis pas méchant mais mais je
je progresse j'ai pas toujours été très
élégant avec mes invités mais aussi à
enrico gare de monaco scouts voile
autorise orlando la kiss à orlando
orlando non il faut pas dire du mal de
lui c'est son anniversaire aujourd'hui
oui oui il a 87 ans après c'est moi qui
me le tap au mathis et après pendant des
soirées entières
c'est stéphane guillon je ne veux plus
que tu les aimes vitus des familles en
août à pau mathis et s'avèrent vains
c'est une façon que malgré le voir
maintenant je vois pas être inquiet
soyons précis chaque emploi si je suis
pas raciste mais mais j'essaye de l'être
c'est bien c'est du boulot quand même
c'est ce que je vis dans un beau
quartier où ma voiture et dans un garage
qui fait donc c'est difficile d'être
raciste quand on a aussi progressé moi
j'ai vrai je fais beaucoup aux femmes
mais je suis l'homme d'une seule femme
c'est vrai jeu plaît beaucoup aux jeunes
mais mais amanda lear s'est toujours
refusé à moi j'aime bien monter sur
scène mais je préfère le vin peut rideau
jeu très ambitieux mais mais pas au
point de changer de coiffure pour piquer
la place de berne
je suis pas de droite mais je suis pas
de droite mais j'aime bien ségolène
royal j'aime bien les gens mais j'aime
bien les gens surtout jean rochefort
jean rochefort
pas évident de tout de suite on voit un
mec robben mais qui fait de la chaîne tu
as il a l'habitude des charges sur les
bills et tout faire du cinéma c'est bien
mais mais sur les dinos ont fait un four
benjamin castaldi est un gros naze mais
mais il a des goûts musicaux trait sur
ces rotors cette interview m
je ne suis pas une sex machine mais mais
la plastique de ma femme me fait
démarrer au quart de tour j'suis veulent
et comme un dieu mais mais je reste
discret j'ai blessé une fois rocco
siffredi
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais pris de drogue mais mais
c'est une c1 et à une conduite quoi un
comportement on est plusieurs à l'avoir
il ya doc gynéco et à florent pagny ya
moi il ya yannick noah on est on est un
petit groupe
je suis pas une [ __ ] mais mais cette
année à cannes a léché augmenté mais
tapie et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux